un acuerdo que sigue generando
esperanzas en medio de la guerra estas
imágenes son del puerto de turno moros
que este domingo otros cuatro barcos
salvaron de las costas ucranianas en el
mar negro cargando más de 170 mil
toneladas de alimentos especialmente
granos principal producto de exportación
de ucrania las embarcaciones son el
glory con 66 mil toneladas de maíz a
bordo con destino a estambul el estar
elena con dirección a nantón china el
río wine rumbo al puerto turco de
iskenderun en el mediterráneo y el
mostafa necati con 6 mil 600 toneladas
de aceite de girasol que llegará a
italia otra embarcación fulmar s se
convirtió en el primer barco comercial
en arribar a ucrania desde el comienzo
de la guerra en febrero estos barcos
sharp han gracias al acuerdo firmado
separadamente el pasado 22 de julio por
moscú y kiev pero sellado gracias a la
mediación turca y de la onu una
operación que se realizará a través de
un centro de coordinación conjunta
establecido en estambul y compuesto por
miembros los rusos turcos y una
delegación de la onu
en el bósforo inspectores turcos revisan
los barcos que entran y salen del mar
negro
la inspección se realiza al nadie estar
de bandera panameña con 33 mil toneladas
de grano que viajan desde la ciudad
ucraniana de odessa hasta irlanda con
este ya son siete las embarcaciones que
logran zarpar desde ucrania producto del
acuerdo el razón y fue el primero de
estos barcos cargando más de 26.000
toneladas de maíz partió desde odessa
con dirección a trípoli en líbano el 1
de agosto su arribo está el
pacto busca sacar 20 millones de granos
estancados en ucrania como consecuencia
de la guerra y logrará aliviar una
inminente crisis alimentaria pues muchos
países especialmente en áfrica dependen
de las exportaciones rusas y ucranianas